>> READY TO GO TONIGHT, COYOTES
PLAYING HOST TO THE CALGARY
FLAM
DALLAS, CAME BACK 3-1 TO WIN
AGAINST THE STARS, AS VERY AGGRS
COYOTES GROUP.
YOU SEE NUMBERS, YOU RED IN FROS
KINGS AND 19 WINNER IN
THE
LANGE RANGE, BUT THEY'VE BROKENY
HAMILTON.
A LOT OF GAMES POSTPONED CHYCHR,
LOOK AT THE BODIES, THE COYOTES
BRING TWO BODIES TO THE FRONT OF
THE
RILEY NASH.
>> NOT THAT TIME, COYOTES, THEY
LOSE THE DRAW AND ITN FRONT.
GAUDREAU HAS THAT'S THE CHEMISTE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
HE JUST GETS OPEN, I 23 SHOTS BE
HE HIT THAT BLUE LINE.
YOU WANT TO HIT THAT BLUE LINE
WITH
GAUDREAU GETS IT RIGHT OPEN AREL
GOAL THE LAST TIME BY
ANTTI RAANTA IN THE THIRD DUMP .
GUDBRANSONON TURNOVER,
SMOOTS KELLER, SIX-GAME
POINT STREAK NOWOW A SHOT, AND .
NOT AGAINST THIS TOP UNIT. A ST.
ANTOINE STRALMAN OUT OF IT BACKT
FOR BACKLUND.
IN THE MIDDLE
TANEV.
NOW FISCHER BEHIND THE NET,
BIG.
THAT IS
BY GAUDREAU.
A 1-1 TURNED INTO A 3-1.
BACK
ON IT IS CHYCHRUN AND FLIPPED
BACK BACKLUND AND AND TOO MUCH
TIME AND SPACE.